TEN MINUTES.
>> ONE OF THE MOST STUNNING
OFFERINGS OF TESTIMONY IN
AMERICAN HISTORY JUST THEN FROM
FORMER WHITE HOUSE AIDE CASSIDY
HUTCHINSON, A TOP AIDE TO THE
THEN WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF STAFF
MARK MEADOWS, DESCRIBING
CONVERSATIONS THAT SHE WAS A
PART OF IN WHICH THERE WERE
WARNINGS OF VIOLENCE BEFORE
JANUARY 6th, DESCRIBING HEARING
DONALD TRUMP ORDERING
INDIVIDUALS TO STOP PUTTING
TRUMP SUPPORTERS THROUGH
MAGNETOMETERS BECAUSE THE
WEAPONS THEY WERE CARRYING, HE
BELIEVED, WERE NOT GOING TO BE
USED AGAINST HIM.
DESCRIBING SECRET SERVICE AGENTS
TALKING ABOUT HOW DONALD TRUMP,
INSIDE THE BEAST, THE SECURE
PRESIDENTIAL LIMO, AFTER THE
JANUARY 6th RALLY, PRESIDENT
TRUMP ORDERING THEM TO TAKE HIM
TO CAPITOL HILL AND WHEN THEY
WOULD NOT DO SO, BECAUSE THEY
DID NOT BELIEVE IT WAS SECURE,
AMONG OTHER REASONS, PRESIDENT
TRUMP, ACCORDING TO THESE SECRET
SERVICE AGENTS, WHO RELAYED THIS
TO CASSIDY HUTCHINSON, LUNGED AT
THE WHOLE AND THEN LUNGED AT THE
THROAT AND CLAVICLE OF HIS
SECRET SERVICE AGENT, ROBERT
ENGEL.
IT WAS DEVASTATING TESTIMONY, A
PORTRAIT OF A PRESIDENT WHO WAS
COMPLETELY AND UTTERLY OUT OF
CONTROL AND WITHOUT QUESTION
KNEW OF THE DANGER OF HIS
SUPPORTERS THAT WERE GOING TO
THE MALL.
AND JAMIE GANGEL, WE HAVE HEARD
A LOT OF SHOCKING THINGS SINCE
DONALD TRUMP CAME DOWN THAT
ESCALATOR IN 2015.
>> RIGHT.
>> THIS WAS OBSCENE.
>> IT IS WORSE THAN WE EVER
IMAGINED.
AND THE NOTION THAT HE WAS SO --
FROM THE NOTION THAT HE WAS SO
OBSESSED WITH HIS CROWD SIZE
THAT HE WANTED PEOPLE COMING IN
WITH WEAPONS TO FILL IT OUT, BUT
TO YOUR POINT, JAKE, THE MOST
SHOCKING THING I THINK WE'VE
HEARD TODAY IS THAT EVERYBODY
KNEW THAT THERE WAS A REAL
CHANCE OF VIOLENCE.
TRUMP CLEARLY KNEW, AND HE
PHYSICALLY GOT INTO AN
ALTERCATION WITH HIS SECRET
SERVICE BECAUSE HE WANTED TO GO
TO THE CAPITOL.
>> I KNOW EVERYBODY WANTS TO
TALK, BUT I DO WANT TO GET TO
THE LEGALITIES OF THIS, LAURA
COATES.
WAS THAT JUST TESTIMONY THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP COMMITTED A
CRIME?
>> I BELIEVE IT IS.
AND WHAT IF THEY HAD THAT AT THE
SECOND IMPEACHMENT HEARING?
THERE WAS ALL SORTS OF NOTIONS
ABOUT WHETHER IT WAS
PREMEDICATED, WHETHER HE HAD
INVITED THE VIOLENCE AT THE
CAPITOL, WHETHER HE KNEW ABOUT
ANY OF THESE DETAILS.
THE IDEA THAT THERE WAS THE
TIMELINE, TWO TO THREE MINUTES
PRIOR TO HIM GOING ON THAT
STAGE, HE WAS AWARE THERE WERE
WEAPONS IN THE CROWD, PEOPLE DID
NOT WANT THEM TO BE GOING
THROUGH THE MAGNETOMETER, THAT
HE WANTED TO KNOW THAT IT WAS
ABOUT THE CROWD SIZE STILL, AND
WAS GOING TO MARCH WITH THEM TO
THE CAPITOLS, BECAUSE HE KNEW
THEY WERE NOT THERE FOR HIM AND
THE TARGET WAS THE ACTUAL PEOPLE
AT CONGRESS, THIS IS SOMEBODY
LAYING OUT METHODICALLY, STATE
OF MIND, PREMEDATION.
>> AND BLOWING AWAY THE LIES OF
TEAM TRUMP, WHICH SAID, THE
CROWD, THEY WERE FRUSTRATED, IT
SPIRALLED OUT OF CONTROL, IT WAS
SPONTANEOUS.
NO, THEY KNEW FOR DAYS THESE
PEOPLE WERE COMING WITH WEAPONS.
MARK MEADOWS TALKING TO SCOTT
PERRY, TALKING TO RUDY GIULIANI,
SHOULD THEY GO INTO THE HOUSE
CHAMBER?
PAT CIPOLLONE REPEATEDLY THE
DAYS BEFOREHAND SAYING, DO NOT
SEND THE PRESIDENT THERE.
IF THE PRESIDENT GETS ANYWHERE
NEAR THERE, THERE ARE BIG LEGAL
CONSEQUENCE, OBSTRUCTING
CONGRESS, OBSTRUCTING THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE COUNT.
THEY KNEW.
>> AND I WANT TO BRING THIS IN,
CASEY, BECAUSE YOU WERE THERE AT
THE CAPITOL THAT DAY.
SO, YOU MIGHT RESPOND TO THIS IN
ADDITION TO AS A JOURNALIST, AS
SOMEBODY WHO WAS LITERALLY UNDER
THREAT.
>> AS A HUMAN.
YEAH.
LOOK, JAKE, HONESTLY, THAT WAS
REALLY HARD TO HEAR.
AND IT REALLY SENT ME BACK TO
THAT DAY AND JUST FOR CONTEXT, I
WAS WITH NBC NEWS AT THE TIME.
I WAS COVERING WHAT WE THOUGHT
WAS GOING TO BE A PRETTY ROUTINE
CERTIFICATION OF THE ELECTION,
BUT WE QUICKLY REALIZED, AS WE
WERE WATCHING THE PRESIDENT'S
SPEECH FROM THE ELLIPSE, THAT
SOMETHING WAS HAPPENING, AND A
COLLEAGUE OF MINE AND I LOOKED
OUT THE WINDOW, EVENTUALLY, OF
THE RUSSELL SENATE OFFICE
BUILDING, WHICH IS WHERE MANY
REPORTERS COVER THESE TYPES OF
EVENTS FROM, AND WE SAW WHAT WAS
HAPPENING, WE LOOKED AT
OURSELVES, WE THOUGHT, WE HAVE
TO TRY TO GET TO THE CAPITOL.
HISTORICALLY, THAT'S THE SAFEST
PLACE TO BE.
THE DOORS WERE ALREADY CHAINED.
AND NOW WE'RE LEARNING THAT, IN
FACT, THE UNITED STATES
PRESIDENT, WHO, LET'S JUST BE
CLEAR, IS SUPPOSED TO BE THE
PRESIDENT FOR ALL AMERICANS,
KNOWINGLY ENCOURAGED, SENT, AND
IN FACT TRIED TO JOIN WHAT HE
KNEW WAS AN ARMED MOB, ARGUABLY
A MILITIA OR AN ARMY, I MEAN,
I'M NOT SURE EXACTLY, WE DON'T
KNOW EXACTLY HOW HE THOUGHT OF
IT BUT HE SENT AN ARMY DOWN TO
TAKE OVER THE UNITED STATES
CAPITOL, INCLUDING ME, MY
COLLEAGUES, AND ALL OF THE
PEOPLE UP THERE.
SO IT'S A PRETTY ASTONISHING
DAY.
>> THE TIMELINE ITSELF IS SO
DAMNING.
10:15 A.M., CASSIDY HUTCHINSON
TESTIFIES THAT THE HEAD OF THE
SECURITY FOR THE WHITE HOUSE AND
THE PRESIDENT CAME TO THE CHIEF
OF STAFF AND SAID, THERE ARE
KNIVES, GUNS, PISTOLS, SPEARS,
FLAG POLES, ORNATO SAID, "THESE
F'ING PEOPLE ARE FASTENING
SPEARS TO THE END OF THEIR
FLAGPOLES."
THEY KNEW